joe biden's campaign
seized the moment this week using the
woodward book to try to change the
subject on the campaign trail
from law and order to the pandemic
joining us now is biden campaign senior
policy adviser
jake sullivan jake joe biden has
blistered president trump's handling of
the coronavirus especially in the wake
of bob woodward's
new book and the revelations in that but
i want to focus
first on joe biden's record in the early
days
of the pandemic on january 27th
biden wrote this for usa today i am
concerned that the trump
administration's
short-sighted policies have left us
unprepared for a dangerous epidemic
that will come sooner or later but the
vice president was holding
mass rallies as late as march 9th
after the cdc had already warned
against those kinds of gatherings how
come
well first chris you're right to point
out that joe biden was warning that we
were dangerously unprepared for a
pandemic in january
and in february he was warning that
china was blocking the access for our
cdc
inspectors to get on the ground to be
able to learn about the virus and
protect the american people
while donald trump was praising their
transparency and in march
he was laying out comprehensive plans
for how he would deal with it as
president
but i want to in march can you answer my
question why was he holding mass rallies
as late as march 9
because he wasn't the president and he
didn't get the information from
government experts telling him this was
deadly and airborne the way president
trump did
he wasn't being told by his national
security adviser
the way that donald trump was that this
was going to be the worst crisis of his
presidency he didn't have access
to the kind of information that donald
trump had and donald trump got all that
information
learned this virus was deadly learned it
was airborne
learned it was worse than the flu and
then lied to the american people and did
nothing about it
that is the difference in the record
between donald trump and joe biden in
this regard
well let's let's talk about another
difference in their record on january
31st president trump
announced travel restrictions
on china that same day here is what
vice president biden had to say
this is no time for donald trump's
record of
hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia
to uh and fear-mongering to lead the way
instead of science
biden denies that he was talking that
day
about the travel restrictions that the
president had just imposed
we didn't believe it was just a
coincidence that he was talking about
xenophobia the day that the president
announced travel restrictions on china
well first of all chris independent fact
checkers including politifact have
looked at the claim
that joe biden was opposed to the china
travel restrictions and they have deemed
that claim
false it's not a coincidence joe biden
was talking about donald trump's record
from the beginning of demonizing chinese
americans of giving names to this virus
of raising questions about whether we
should trust asian americans
this is something donald trump has been
doing over the course of his four years
is using xenophobia and fear-mongering
in the moment of crisis rather than
actually doing his job
what joe biden said was that these
travel bans can slow the virus
but they can't stop the virus and that's
what the record reflects
despite the fact that there were
restrictions put in place both with
respect to china and europe we have 200
000 people dead
and 6 million cases and the reason why
is because donald trump didn't do his
job
with respect to testing well but i want
to focus again on this with respect to
focus on this because your campaign your
campaign
didn't say you say well the fact
checkers say he didn't oppose it
your campaign didn't say that biden
approved of the travel restrictions
until april why did it taken
so long and would you agree that
the president moving so much faster
january
31st to impose travel restrictions when
biden
didn't formally come out in support of
the travel restrictions on china
until april 3rd that by the trump's
actions
saved thousands of lives
first of all chris the virus was already
in the united states by the time that
that donald trump imposed these
restrictions
why did it take biden two months to
approve the
to approve the travel restrictions
well first it didn't take him two months
in a speech on march 12th joe biden said
the travel restrictions can slow the
virus
but they can't stop the virus his whole
point was the only way long term
for us to get this virus under control
is for the president to stand up and do
his job
here at home where the virus was
circulating that's why he was placing so
much emphasis
on the kinds of things other countries
did to get the virus under control
testing ppe resources all things
donald trump didn't do so that on friday
of this week more than a thousand
americans died
and in canada zero did that is the
difference in failed leadership in the
united states and the kind of effective
leadership that joe biden would have
brought to bear had he been president
throughout this entire crisis i want to
talk
about another subject because president
trump has been hitting
joe biden hard on the issue of law and
order he says that that will be
threatened if joe biden
is elected president in portland oregon
you see the videos here there have been
more than a hundred days of protests
often violent
does the president think the mayor of
that city
and the governor of the state have
handled the
hundred days of protests and riots
in portland properly
you said does the president believe that
or do you mean vice
president if i if i said that i met vice
president biden
vice president biden believes that the
the single biggest difference
between success and failure with respect
to
safety in these communities has been
donald trump not the local leadership it
has been donald trump pouring gasoline
on the fire
and causing more damage more wreckage
more division more violence inciting his
supporters for example to drive convoys
through the streets
firing paintball and and spraying pepper
spray
on protesters that's what joe biden
wants to stop but
violence jake
it's up to the the the mayor to call out
the police force it's up to the governor
to call out the national guard
don't they bear some responsibility for
the hundred days can you really say
it's president trump and washington is
causing all the protests
or more importantly failing to stop all
the protests
of court of course of course
uh responsibility lodges at every level
of government local state etc
but chris here's the important point
there were democratic mayors
and a democratic governor in portland
and in oregon
when joe biden was vice president and
you didn't see this happening
joe biden and donald and and barack
obama protected federal property without
having to send in militias
joe biden and barack obama cut the
violent crime rate by 15 percent in this
country
without inciting more lawlessness and
more chaos and more violence on the
streets so the real
difference in what we're seeing today is
a difference in leadership in the white
house that chooses to inflame every
situation rather than try to calm them
down
don't you think the fact that we've had
george floyd and the reaction from that
don't you think that's played a role in
it that it again
i don't can you really blame all this on
president trump of course
of course the point that i'm making is
that
at a moment like this at a crisis moment
like this the single most
important thing that we need from the
white house
is an effort to reduce tension to calm
the situation down to call out violence
wherever it comes from and frankly
donald trump has simply been
unwilling to call out violence from
right-wing militias joe biden has said
whether it's from the left or the right
violence is wrong donald trump has been
too scared to do that because he doesn't
want to take on his own people
so i'm not sitting here saying that
every last aspect of this
falls at the feet of the white house of
course not but what i am
saying is that one of the biggest
differences between how things operated
under the obama biden administration and
how they operate in donald trump's
america
is that we have leadership in the white
house that is pouring gasoline on the
fire
rather than trying to bring a
significant amount of progress towards
greater safety in our communities
jake thank you thanks for your time this
sunday please come back